everybody is self-quarantine eing right
now a lot of people are in isolation and
that brings up a delicate matter which
is the matter of sex being sexually
healthy and stimulated in this
quarantined environment in isolation I
thought I would go to an expert a
professional sex therapist dr. Emily
Morse
hi Emily how are you and if you have to
be and to deal with your partner in sex
because of Technology are you talking
about sexy phone calls
sexy taxes that's what you're talking
about talking about sexting here's my
number one rule you got to make sure
that someone's available right you don't
know if she's gonna see their phone what
if someone's around but if they're later
you say a great thing is I can't stop
thinking about you I can't stop thinking
about you I used to try that line a lot
and it very rapidly got into stalker
territory you know I would say I can't
stop thinking about you I know where you
live I went by your place last night I
smelled your mail
what about like oh I'm all covered in
baby oil do people like that how about
this right now I'm picturing rubbing oil
on your back and you arching your back
and and it feels it feels so good and
I'm getting I'm getting to the low back
I'm working on between the l4 and l5
there's you've had some tightness there
in the past and I'm trying to break up
the fascia when you get a dick pic for
example nobody's sitting there going oh
I give me a clock out of Monday even in
court English I got a dick pic right now
is it dick pic ever appropriate because
what I've always heard from women is
they don't like the look of a penis they
think it's not big enough there's too
much red pubic hair it it swings wildly
for some reason to the right it looks
scarred those are the things that some
of us are hearing oh my I tried to get
the face in with the penis and I don't
I'm not flexible enough you seen
I hear you that's why you all might be
good for you then is the video is video
chat you can pan down angles and the
lighting I need really good lighting
yeah it's been an issue there's people I
can't see it where is it it blends with
the leg you get a lot of dick pics
people who are like stopping the dips
yeah have a team of people who are
penises are coming at you like missiles
in some 1980s video game and you know
people that are squatting way to protect
you from incoming and and I want to talk
to you a little bit about emojis
what emojis are common to stimulate a
sexual conversation this is all by
preference but I believe that people
like the eggplant or the banana for the
penis people like the there's the water
for the ejaculate a pussycat Records is
the vagina in some places I will say I'm
glad that you brought up you clarified
the cat because I did think once that I
was supposed to go have sex with our cat
you know with a cat cat got away it was
a mess well I'm also curious about sex
toys so this is a vibrator they're
wonderful for men and for women and it
works with your phone so we vibe and use
your phone you launch it and you can
just control this vibrator from anywhere
in the world I'm sorry I need help here
so watching it's over here I understand
where it would go for a woman but that
shape how does that work for a guy
it feels amazing on your shaft your all
of your body it's interesting you say
that because I used to get aroused on
the Macy's escalator and I realized only
much later on and security explained
this to me it's the vibrations you know
they they were kind enough to talk me
through it as they ejected me from
Macy's this one this
around your penis now that we're getting
specific they make like a bunch of them
so this one it's one size fits most
you'll be fine
wait so that goes around the penis
you're at the store and all of a sudden
I can just launch this and I can buy me
this is on you and I'm then it starts to
move it starts to vibrate and it's the
best trip to the grocery store you've
ever had Oh get specific here but we're
I to have an orgasm in a grocery store I
think it would be very upsetting for a
lot of people should it should we be
discouraging people from orgasming while
they're trying to pick out which
freeze-dried risotto to get little
titillation I tend to get there very
quickly I mean literally all you'd have
to do is just text me one hashtag and if
that thing just fired for a second I'd
be spinning around like a Three Stooges
on the floor you don't I'm saying
masturbation and self-pleasure
always it's like all the time I mean
what about civilization would crumble if
we just did it all the time we need to
farm we need to get goods to the stores
it's actually good for us orgasms
they all do release all the feel-good
hormones it actually improve your mood
your your boost your immunity doctor
foul Qi
has been on the air talking to everybody
about what to do during this quarantine
he never brings up masturbation and I've
called CNN many times while he's on the
air and tried to get a question in about
pleasuring myself and they never let me
through and I feel like pouchy is
sending the wrong message he should be
talking to us about masturbating about
putting vibrating you know machines into
our pants and I think the fact that he
isn't is really a national crime and I
think he should be prosecuted
dr. Emily Morris thank you very much and
this was a delight and maybe I'll check
in with you later on in in the coming
weeks or maybe in an hour or so yeah I
might just drive by alright I'm a Cree
but you're wonderful thank you very much